[Music]
first of all you would do what with
Beyonce how did that happen do you have
her phone number do you text her do you
have your people call her people I have
an email address email um that actually
changes every week oh she's like she's
very good at hiding yeah it's kind of
like it's kind of like what I aspire to
be I think but yeah I have an email so I
emailed that and then we got on the
phone and yeah I mean it's kind of it's
been in the works since May obviously
she had twins and yeah we've we finished
it in September so I've been holding on
Citizens Center
so he's listening to our on the way over
and I thought now when you get it back
from Beyonce do you give her a note and
say like yo B I was hoping you'd do it a
little different here do you just take
what she because she she rung me up so
the original version of perfect was just
an acoustic it's her and she rung me up
and was like I don't know how you feel
about this but taking all the
instruments off it and it's just gonna
be that's great so it used to be that
and then when we got in together it
wasn't so much notes it was just we it
was very much like a back-and-forth
thing like what do you think of this yes
what do you think of this and yeah
probably took probably in a studio for
like four hours
yeah what did you learn from Queen B ed
one take vocals yeah she just yeah he
was she was just like right went in once
I came out yeah it sounds all right
that's how the Queen does it Edie are
you going to sing at the real wedding I
get asked this all the time like I know
the royal family I've met Harry once you
want to yeah I mean if you know the time
if I if I was free I probably would do
you need my help this year because I
know you have a special lady in your
life with gifting gifting know what I
got our art lessons oh she wants it to
learn how to draw so I've our art
lessons she knows however yeah she knows
this cuz I had to like work out at David
yeah
[Music]
you